Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere.
Kosmische Angelegenheiten.
Mein Name ist Tim Pridlaff und ich begrüße alle hier zu einer weiteren Ausgabe
rund um das CERN, was ich derzeit besuche und wo ich versuche mir mal alles
genau erklären zu lassen, was hier alles so rumliegt.
Und was hier vor allem rumliegt, sind Ringe.
Große Ringe, in denen sehr viel beschleunigt wird und das ist ja hier so ein bisschen,
das ermöglichende Infrastruktur, die diverse Detektoren und zahlreiche Experimente
ja überhaupt erst zum Leben bringt.
Und um darüber mal zu quatschen, wie das so funktioniert, begrüße ich meinen
Gesprächspartner, nämlich den Alexander Huschauer. Hallo.
Hallo.
Herzlich willkommen bei Raumzeit.
Vielen Dank, freut mich sehr hier zu sein.
Du bist, wie es so schön heißt, Staff Accelerator Physicist and Engineer in
Charge of the CERN Proton Synchrotron in the BEOPS Section. Das kannst du mir
jetzt gleich mal aufdröseln, was das jetzt bedeutet.
Das bedeutet, dass ich im BEAMS Department arbeite. Das ist jenes Department,
das eben zuständig ist für die Produktion der Strahlen am CERN.
Dort in der Operations Group, also wirklich an den Beschleunigern selbst arbeite
und PS, das Protonen-Synchrotron.
Wir sind in verschiedene Abteilungen aufgeteilt in der Operations Group für
die verschiedenen Beschleuniger. Und in meinem Fall bin ich eben Engineer in
Charge vom Protonen-Synchrotron.
Einer der ältesten Beschleuniger, den wir hier am CERN haben,
1959 in Betrieb gegangen.
Schöne komplexe Maschine und eben ein Teil der Beschleunigerkette.
Genau, aber du kennst ja die ganze Kette und darüber wollen wir jetzt nämlich mal ein bisschen reden.
Und man sagt Kette, warum sagt man Kette, weil alles hier miteinander verbunden ist?
Alles ist miteinander verbunden. Die verschiedenen Ringe, wie du gesagt hast,
sind über sogenannte Transferlinien miteinander verbunden, so dass wir von einem
Ring zum nächsten Ring die Teilchen schicken können.
Mit der Idee dahinter, dass in jedem Ring die Energie der Teilchen immer höher und höher wird.
Man hat da technologische, physikalische Limits, wie hoch man Teilchen in einem
Ring beschleunigen kann und deswegen braucht man wirklich so eine Kette von Beschleunigern,
um dann höchste Energien, wie
eben im Large Hadron Collider am Schluss der Kette, erreichen zu können.
Genau, da wollen wir uns dann gleich mal auf die Reise machen und mal so ein
bisschen rauskriegen, was es dafür im Detail dann alles so erfordert.
Jetzt will ich aber erstmal nochmal ein bisschen wissen, wie du denn hier überhaupt
zu der Tätigkeit gekommen bist. Seit wann betreibst du denn Wissenschaft und warum?
Ich bin jetzt seit ungefähr zwölf Jahren am CERN.
Schulisch habe ich eine technische Ausbildung gemacht. Ich habe damals eine
Ausbildung in Mechatronik gemacht, wie es bei uns in Österreich spezielle Schulstufen
gibt, also im Prinzip noch vor der Universität.
Ich war dann immer schon technisch begeistert und natürlich viel mit Physik,
Optik, Elektronik, Mechanik in Kontakt gekommen.
Und dann hat mich das Studium der Physik gereizt, Technische Physik an der Uni
Wien, an der Technischen Uni Wien.
Und dort so eigentlich im Laufe der Zeit mir gedacht, Grundlagenforschung eher
nicht so meins, glaube ich werde ich nie hinkommen, es wird mich mehr eher so
in die Industrie treiben dann irgendwann mal.
Aber dann habe ich ein paar Vorlesungen belegt im Bereich der Teilchenphysik
und später dann noch eine Vorlesung im Bereich der Beschleunigerphysik.
Und das war so mein Einstieg. Mein Einstieg hier ins CERN im Prinzip,
weil es ist wirklich eine coole Möglichkeit, um all diese verschiedenen,
so Physik einerseits, Engineering andererseits zusammenzubringen.
Und gerade im Betrieb eines Beschleunigers kommt man tagtäglich mit all diesen Dingen in Kontakt.
Und das ist wirklich das, was für mich den Reiz ausmacht.
Alles andere ist eine langweilige Tätigkeit. Jeden Tag unterschiedliche Herausforderungen,
denen man gegenübersteht.
Ja und dann habe ich damals meine Diplomarbeit hier gemacht,
bin hier geblieben für ein Doktorat und bin jetzt seit 2017 angestellt Star Physicist am CERN.
Im Prinzip arbeitest du ja wirklich im Kern am Betriebssystem des ZERN,
könnte man sagen, weil ohne das System wäre hier kein Betrieb möglich.
Absolut.
Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen. Es ist immer ganz interessant so eine Disziplin
zu haben, die eigentlich dann sehr viel Überschneidung hat mit anderen Bereichen.
Ja, na dann gucken wir doch mal, was hier eigentlich alles vorzufinden ist.
Vielleicht blicken wir mal so von oben erstmal auf diesen ganzen Komplex.
Ich hab mir irgendwann mal so eine Karte in Google Earth reingeladen,
die sozusagen die ganzen Zernringe so einfach mal so in ihrer räumlichen Ausdehnung mit einblendet.
Da merkt man erstmal schon, ganz schön groß alles.
Insbesondere natürlich der große Ring, aber ist ja auch nicht der einzige.
Was findet man sozusagen vor, wenn man jetzt diesen Bird's Eye View auf das CERN macht?
Also man findet in erster Linie verschiedene Orte. Also das CERN hat einen Hauptstandort,
der im Kanton Genf liegt, in Maran.
Dort sind die älteren, kleineren Beschleuniger des CERNs zu finden.
Und von dort weg, die nächsten Maschinen, die sind dann doch etwas größer.
Also wenn man sagt, die kleineren Maschinen haben so bis zu einer Länge von
630 Metern, die sich am Campus selbst befinden.
Und danach die nächsten Maschinen, 7 km oder 27 km, die sind dann schon unter
der Erde gebaut und auch wesentlich dann über den Campus des Zerns hinausgehend.
Und zum großen Teil eigentlich in Frankreich liegen die. Und wenn man sich so
Luftlinien anschaut, wenn wir uns gerade den LHC anschauen mit seinem 27 km Umfang, von.
Den Punkt, wo die Strahlen indiziert werden in die Maschine bis zum gegenüberliegenden
Punkt haben wir doch acht Kilometer Luftlinie.
Also das ist wirklich groß und wenn wir so zum Anfang dieser Kette gehen,
dann haben wir dort eine ganz kleine Quelle.
Weil was wir machen hier, einerseits beschleunigen wir Protonen,
um die dann später kollidieren zu können in verschiedenen Experimenten.
Andererseits machen wir das auch mit Ionen, also zum Beispiel Bleionen.
Aber in der Vergangenheit auch verschiedene andere Ionen. Die müssen irgendwo
erzeugt werden, diese Teilchen, bevor man sie überhaupt mal in einen Beschleuniger senden kann.
Und dann ist es eben wichtig, dass man Schritt für Schritt die Energie dieser
Teilchen erhöht, um am Schluss die Energien, die die Experimente verlangen, produzieren zu können.
Und warum brauchen wir da überhaupt hohe Energien? Das ist einerseits,
ist die Energiedichte wichtig. Was wir machen, sind Kollisionen.
Wir schießen Protonen auf Protonen, wir kollidieren.
Und die Energie, die diese Protonenstrahlen haben, die können über die Energie
ist gleich Masse, Lichtgeschwindigkeit zum Quadratformel umgewandelt werden.
Also Energie kann in Masse umgewandelt werden, sprich aus der Energie der Strahlen
können wir neue Teilchen erzeugen und diese neuen Teilchen können dann einfach
von den Experimenten detektiert, untersucht, charakterisiert werden.
Und andererseits, wenn wir vielleicht das Band ein bisschen zur Kosmologie,
Astronomie spannen, da verwenden wir Teleskope, um in den Weltraum hineinzuschauen,
um sich große Strukturen anzuschauen, Galaxien, Sterne dergleichen.
Was wir machen hier ist genau das andere Ende der Größenordnung.
Wir untersuchen die kleinsten Details der Materie.
Und wie kommt man dorthin? Mit einem Mikroskop, mit optischem Licht,
kann man sich bestimmte Teile sehr schön vergrößern. Irgendwann kommt man ans Limit.
Das hängt einfach von der Wellenlänge des Lichts ab.
Wenn man jetzt immer höher und höher auflösen, also in die Materie hineinschauen
möchte, braucht man im Prinzip immer kleinere und kleinere Wellenlängen.
Die Wellenlänge ist indirekt proportional zur Energie. Das heißt,
ich brauche extrem hohe Energien, um geringe Wellenlängen zu erzeugen und dann
einfach diese kleinsten Details der Materie auflösen zu können.
Und so gehen wir dann mit den Beschleunigern, die im Endeffekt nichts anderes
als ein super Mikroskop sind,
gehen wir wirklich hinein in den Atomkern, in die Bestandteile,
die Protonen, Neutronen, die Quarks und all die Teilchen, die man dann noch
erzeugen kann in Kollisionen.
Ich fand es interessant, dass du von dem Ring als Maschine gesprochen hast,
weil das muss man sich halt auch klar machen.
Man denkt halt erstmal so, ja Beschleunigerring, da ist halt so ein Tunnel, da fliegt das rum.
Das machen ja die Teilchen jetzt nicht von alleine, sondern im Prinzip sprechen
wir wirklich von einer 27 Kilometer langen Maschine,
die also wirklich über die gesamte Strecke in irgendeiner Form Technik bereithält,
um letzten Endes das durchzuführen.
Also wir haben es mit einem Megamaschinenpark zu tun, der sich räumlich extrem
ausdehnt, um eben am Ende Kollisionen messen zu können.
Die anderen Sendungen, die ich hier mache, werden sich also im Detail den einzelnen
Detektoren widmen, der ja hier mehrerlei installiert sind. Alice, Atlas, CMS und das LACB.
Nebst, da kommen wir vielleicht auch noch gleich drauf, vielen kleineren Experimenten,
die ja auch noch mit dabei sind.
Aber alle haben eigentlich denselben Bedarf. brauchen eben diese beschleunigten,
hochenergetischen Teile, egal welcher Teil eines Atoms das jetzt sozusagen ist.
Also nur die Protonen und die ganze Atomkerne etc.
Ja, wo fangen wir an? Also es muss ja erst mal, das was man schießt,
muss ja auch erst mal da sein.
Dafür braucht man eine Quelle.
Da geht's los. Man braucht eine Quelle. Das ist hier so der Fachbegriff.
Das ist genau Source auf Englisch. Und in unserem Fall ist es so,
dass um diese Protonen zu erzeugen, beginnen wir mit Wasserstoff.
Sprich am Anfang der Quelle ist eine Wasserstoffquelle oder eine Wasserstoffflasche im Prinzip.
Warum Wasserstoff?
Weil Wasserstoff aus Protonen und Elektronen besteht und wir wollen dieses Proton
haben, das da in Neutronen kennt. Alles besteht ja aus Elektronen.
Natürlich, aber es ist relativ einfach, dieses Elektron zu entfernen und dann
nur mit diesem Proton überzubleiben.
Auch Wasserstoff ist natürlich weiter verfügbar, ist sehr leicht zu bekommen,
herzustellen und als Grundstoff im Prinzip zu verwenden.
Dieses Gas wird eingelassen in diese Quelle. In dieser Quelle wird das Gas dann erhitzt,
und mit einem Magnetfeld, eigentlich mit einem wechselnden Magnetfeld,
das dazu führt, dass sich die Teilchen in diesem Gas immer schneller und schneller
bewegen, dass das Gas ionisiert wird, sprich, dass die Teilchen auch,
dass die Elektronen sich loslösen von dem Proton und dass man im Endeffekt ein Plasma erzeugt.
Also einen Zustand, wo ionisierte Teilchen herumflitzen, wenn man so möchte.
Und in dem ersten Teil unserer Kette ist es aber so, dass wir gar noch nicht
das Proton verwenden, sondern ein negativ geladenes Wasserstoffatom.
Sprich, wir Wir fügen im Prinzip dem Wasserstoff einmal in erster Linie noch ein Elektron hinzu.
Und dann wird dieser negativ geladene Wasserstoff aus der Quelle mit Elektroden
rausbeschleunigt, rausgezogen, rausgesaugt im Prinzip.
Und danach, nach dieser Quelle, das sind wirklich die ersten zwei Meter der
Beschleunigeranlage, geht es in einen Linearbeschleuniger.
Und dieser Linearbeschleuniger ist die effizienteste Möglichkeit,
um Teilchen möglichst schnell einerseits zu fokussieren, weil man muss sich
vorstellen, wenn die Teilchen aus der Quelle herauskommen, haben die auch Winkelverteilungen.
Das heißt, die haben eigentlich die Tendenz, in alle Richtungen gestreut zu
werden. Jetzt möchte man die transversal, also horizontal und vertikal,
möglichst fokussieren, aber gleichzeitig sie nach vorne beschleunigen,
also ihnen mehr Energie geben.
Und das passiert in erster Linie in einem sogenannten RFQ, Radio Frequency Quadrupole.
Radio Hochfrequenter Quadrupole.
Da kann man vielleicht noch dazu sagen, dass ein Beschleuniger so Grundbausteine hat.
Und wenn man sich jetzt so einen Linearbeschleuniger anschaut,
hat er eben als einen Grundbaustein die Hochfrequenz-Elemente,
Hochfrequenz-Kavitäten, wie wir sagen, die dazu dienen mittels elektrischen
Feldern, Energie an die Teilchen zu übergeben und sie zu beschleunigen.
Und andererseits gibt es Quadrupole, die sind magnetischer Natur,
das heißt wir haben ein magnetisches Quadrupolfeld, das dazu dient die Teilchen
zu fokussieren, horizontal und Transfersaal dafür zu sorgen, dass die eben nicht...
Auseinanderlaufen und im Endeffekt verloren gehen.
Die werden sozusagen durch Magnetfelder so eingerahmt und in Spur gesetzt.
Alles passiert natürlich in einer Vakuumkammer, weil wir möglichst wenig Kollisionen
mit dem Restgas haben möchten, um die Anzahl der Teilchen relativ hoch zu halten.
Dementsprechend bewegen sich die Teilchen in einer Vakuumkammer und außen herum
sind eben diese magnetischen Felder und teilweise gibt es dann Öffnungen in
den Vakuumkammern, wo eben diese elektrischen Felder wirken und die Teilchen beschleunigen können.
Ich hab jetzt noch nicht so ganz verstanden, warum man jetzt erstmal noch einen
Elektron hinzufügt und dann aus dieser Quelle diese, wie nennt man das dann,
wenn das Proton mit zwei Elektronen versorgt ist?
Das negativ geladene Wasserstoffatom.
Das negativ geladene Wasserstoffatom. Das ist ja eigentlich nicht das,
was wir auf die Reise schicken wollen. Warum wird denn das rausgezogen? Noch nicht.
Wir hatten auch bis 2018 haben wir rein Protonen beschleunigt und zwischen 2019
und 2020 gab es hier ein Upgrade-Programm,
wo viele der Beschleuniger in ihrer Leistungsfähigkeit verbessert wurden und
einer der Schritte war eben diesen neuen Linak, diesen neuen Linearbeschleuniger
zu installieren, der H-, negativgeladene Wasserstoffatome, beschleunigt.
Und das ist dazu da, dass man dann eigentlich in der nächsten Maschine,
der erste Ringbeschleuniger ist, die Teilchendichte erhöhen kann und somit eine
größere Anzahl von Teilchen in einer kleineren Fläche zusammenpacken kann.
Weil das ist das, was im Endeffekt bei Experimenten wie beim LHC zählt.
Es ist, dass man möglichst viele Kollisionen zusammenbekommt.
Und wie bekommt man mehr und mehr Kollisionen zusammen? indem man einerseits
die Anzahl der Teilchen erhöht oder andererseits die Strahldimensionen verkleinert,
damit, wenn man sie aufeinander schießt, möglichst viele Teilchen miteinander kollidieren.
Das heißt wir gehen dann durch diesen Linak, wo Stück für Stück die Energie
der Teilchen erhöht wird mit verschiedenen Kavitäten,
verschiedenen Arten von Kavitäten und am Ende der Quelle haben wir zum Beispiel
45 Kiloelektronenvolt an Energie.
Das heißt, die Quelle hat 45 Kilowolt und wenn die Ladung da durchgeht,
dann spricht man davon, dass die Teilchen auf 45 Kiloelektronenvolt beschleunigt wurden.
Im Prinzip, wenn man sich eine Batterie hernimmt mit einem Volt,
ein Teilchen, das von einem Volt beschleunigt wird, hätte am Ende einen Elektronenvolt.
Und das sind diese Energieskalen, die wir am CERN verwenden,
um unsere Beschleuniger zu definieren.
Welche Größenordnungen von Energien, die im Prinzip den Teilchen geben können.
Jetzt sind wir am Ende dieses Linux, sind wir von den 45 kEV am Beginn zu 160
Megaelektronenvolt, 160 MeV gekommen.
Und dann gehen wir in die erste Transferlinie.
Warte mal kurz. Das Beschleunigen mit diesen Hohlräumen, diesen Kavitäten,
was genau beschleunigt denn jetzt diese Elemente?
Also was führt dazu, dass sie schneller unterwegs sind? Weil da muss ja irgendwie
Energie übertragen werden und nur so ein Magnetfelder nebenhalten allein reicht
ja nicht. Das ist zum Ablenken vielleicht ganz gut und zum Ausrichten,
aber da wird man ja noch nicht automatisch schneller von.
Da wird man überhaupt nicht schneller davon, ganz genau. Deswegen braucht man elektrische Felder.
Mit Magnetfeldern können wir die Teilchen manipulieren. Wir können sie eben
fokussieren oder auch auf Kreisbahnen lenken.
Aber dann brauchen wir elektrische Felder, um wirklich die Energie der Teilchen erhöhen zu können.
Sprich, man muss sich das so vorstellen, dass wir oszillierende elektrische
Felder haben Und die Teilchen im Prinzip.
Angesorgt werden von diesem elektrischen Feld, wenn es die richtige Polarität
hat, je nachdem welche Ladung.
Sprich, wir haben einen negativ geladenen Wasserstoff, der wird von einem positiven
elektrischen Feld angezogen.
Danach wird das umgepolt, sodass das Feld negativ wird, wenn das geladene Teilchen
vorbei ist und dann wieder abgestoßen wird.
Und so müssen wir schön synchronisiert Stück für Stück entlang des Beschleunigers dafür sorgen,
dass diese Polaritäten der Felder immer so sind, dass wir im Endeffekt eine
kontinuierliche Beschleunigung entlang der Maschine erhalten.
Also im Prinzip wie bei einer Schaukel, wo man dann auch im richtigen Moment
sein Gewicht so verlagert,
dass man dann immer genau schiebt, wenn man es braucht und sich nach vorne verlegt
zurück und dadurch quasi die eigene Bewegungsenergie, Also wenn man sie richtig
timet, auf die Schaukel überträgt und dann schaukelt es immer schneller.
Ganz genau und wenn man sie falsch timet, dann bleibt das Teilchen stehen.
Okay, verstehe. Und das machen diese Hohlraum- Hochfrequenz-Kavitäten.
Hochfrequenz-Kavitäten.
Weil sie eben mit sehr hohen Frequenzen arbeiten. In dem LIMNAC zum Beispiel
mit 350 Megahertz oszilliert dieses elektrische Feld dann.
Aber wie synchronisiert sich denn dann dieses elektrische Feld?
Da muss man ja quasi sehr genau wissen wie schnell das Teilchen schon ist.
Muss man das messen oder ergibt sich das?
Im Linac ist das ein Teil des Designs der Maschine.
Man muss sagen im Prinzip gibt es da einen sogenannten Driftube Linac.
Das heißt, die Teilchen fliegen durch kleine Röhrchen, in denen sie abgeschirmt
werden von dem elektrischen Feld. Und währenddem sie abgeschirmt werden, wird das Feld umgepolt.
So, dass wenn das Teilchen am Ende dieser Röhre herauskommt,
es genau wieder beschleunigt wird, weil das Feld die richtige Polarität hat.
Dann gibt es aber jetzt nicht nur eine so eine Röhre in so einem Linearbeschleuniger, es gibt viele.
Und die Teilchen werden schneller und schneller und schneller.
Die Frequenz dieses elektrischen Felds bleibt aber konstant.
Dementsprechend müssen diese Röhren, in denen die Teilchen abgeschirmt werden,
auch immer länger und länger werden. Also im Inneren so eines Drift-Tube-Linux.
Und ja, so ist das eine Anordnung von verschiedenen Röhren, wo dazwischen dann
Beschleunigung stattfindet in einem Linearbeschleuniger, in einem Kreisbeschleuniger
sieht das Ganze wieder ein bisschen anders aus.
Okay, aber der Linearbeschleuniger ist jetzt sozusagen erstmal dafür da,
die Source erstmal anzuzapfen, überhaupt erstmal die Teilchen,
die man haben will, die man beschleunigen möchte, rauszunehmen und dann eben
über diese Methodik erstmal auf so eine Grundgeschwindigkeit zu bringen und nicht nur das,
sondern auch gerade auszurichten, dass sie einfach eine klare Richtung haben
und das sowohl in horizontaler, als auch in vertikaler Sicht.
Also man weiß, wo man hinschießt und man weiß, wie schnell man schießt und wo
der Strahl sich befindet und dann kann es eigentlich erst so richtig losgehen.
Und man weiß auch, welche Größe der Strahl hat. Das ist wesentlich nachher für
die Experimente und welche Energie. Also das natürlich geht mit der Geschwindigkeit einigermaßen.
Aber nicht alle Detektoren schreien
ja jetzt nach Wasserstoffatomen oder beziehungsweise nach Protonen.
Aber der Großteil, sagen wir mal, also wir haben eben den Großteil des Jahres
am CERN machen wir Protonenphysik.
Wir machen meistens am Ende des Jahres, haben wir einen Monat Ionenphysik,
wo wir dann Bleionen verwenden. Aber den Rest des Jahres machen wir eigentlich immer Protonenphysik.
Natürlich ist es dann so, dass die Experimente selbst nicht unbedingt die Protonen
brauchen, aber aus den Protonen werden eventuelle Sekundärteilchen erzeugt,
die dann wirklich von den Experimenten verwendet werden.
Und das Blei, wo kommt das her?
Das kommt aus einer anderen Quelle. Also im Prinzip gibt es diese Wasserstoffquelle,
es gibt eine Bleiquelle mit einem anderen Linak.
Dort funktioniert das ein bisschen anders, da gibt es so ein kleines Stück 10
Gramm schwerer Blei, das aufgeheizt wird, wo dann diese Bleiatome eben in eine Kammer hineinkommen.
Dort auch wird wieder ein Plasma angeregt, in dem man mit Mikrowellen die ganze Struktur anregt.
Die Teilchen dazu führen, dass sie ionisiert werden und dort werden die dann
aus einer Quelle genauso herausgesaugt und in einen anderen Linang,
der ein bisschen anders funktioniert, aber vom Prinzip her das gleiche ist,
Teilchen beschleunigen, Strahlgröße definieren, vorbereitet.
Also man macht sich quasi durch Hitze so eine Art Bleigas und dann geht es wenig weiter.
Absolut, genau. Und am Ende dieser Linearbeschleuniger gibt es dann eine Transferlinie,
die jeweils zu dem ersten Ringbeschleuniger die Teilchen bringt.
Und wenn wir zurück in zu der Protonenkette, dann ist nach dem LINAK 4,
der eben unser erster Beschleuniger ist, der diesen Wasserstoff beschleunigt.
Wenn er der erste ist, warum heißt er dann 4?
Ja, weil es davor 1, 2 gab. 3 ist der für die Ionen und 4 ist der neue,
der jetzt eben 2019 quasi in Betrieb genommen wurde.
Also die die neueste Version.
Und dann gehen wir hinein in den Booster, den Proton-Synchrotron-Booster,
der die erste kreisförmige Maschine ist.
Unsere Kreisbeschleuniger, die nennen wir Synchrotron. Da sage ich dann auch
nochmal dazu vielleicht warum genau. Also gehen wir zu den Bestandteilen,
die wir brauchen. Beim LINAC hatten wir jetzt schon die Hochfrequenz-Kavitäten
und Quadrupole zum Fokussieren.
Ein wesentlicher Bestandteil für einen Ringbeschleuniger fehlt uns jetzt noch,
das sind die Dipolmagnete.
Dipolmagnete haben ein konstantes magnetisches Feld und geladene Teilchen in
einem Dipolmagnet werden auf eine Kreisbahn gelenkt.
Und das ist eben das, was es uns ermöglicht, die Teilchen im Kreis zu senden,
in sogenannten Synchrotrons, in diesen Kreisbeschleunigern.
Und mit diesen Quadrupolmagneten kommt es auch in diesen Maschinen zur transversalen
Fokussierung und dann gibt es eben noch genauso Hochfrequenz-Kavitäten in den
Maschinen, die auch dort dazu führen, dass die Teilchen beschleunigt werden.
Es ist ein großer Unterschied aber zum LINAK, weil beim LINAK gehen diese Teilchen
durch zum Beispiel beim LINAK 4 86 Meter einmal durch.
Die werden einfach einmal beschleunigt und dann ist die Beschleunigung dort erledigt.
Bei dem Kreisbeschleuniger nützt man jetzt aus, dass man wesentlich kleinere
elektrische Spannungen hat, kleinere Beschleunigung bekommt,
aber dafür eben oftmals im Kreis geht. Und jedes Mal, wenn das Teilchen vorbeikommt,
wenn es im Kreis geht, wird es mehr und mehr und mehr beschleunigt.
Wenn es jetzt mehr beschleunigt wird, sagen wir auch, dass es im Prinzip more
rigid wird, rigider, und Es lässt sich.
Also die Ablenkung in einem gleichbleibenden Magnetfeld wird immer weniger und weniger.
Um ein Teilchen, das immer höhere und höhere Energie bekommt,
weiterhin auf einer gleichen Kreisbahn halten zu können,
muss man auch das Magnetfeld der Dipole nach oben fahren, so damit eben der
Kreisbeschleuniger hat eben eine Vakuumkammer und die Teilchen müssen idealerweise
im Zentrum dieser Vakuumkammer bleiben.
Wenn sie davon zu weit ausgelenkt werden, dann werden sie irgendwann die Kammer
treffen und dann sind sie weg.
Und deswegen heißen die Maschinen Synchrotron, weil synchron mit der Beschleunigung
muss man das Magnetfeld der Dipole und im weiteren Sinne auch der Quadropole
erhöhen, damit man die Teilchen auf der gleichen Kreisbahn halten kann.
Und die erhöht man, indem man da mehr Strom reinsteckt?
Für die Magnete, ganz genau. Konventionelle Magnete, Eisenmagnete,
die wir hier verwenden, die gehen so bis 1,2 Tesla Magnetfeld hinauf.
Das sind normal leitende dann.
Und wenn man dann an den LAC schaut, dann verwenden wir dort eben supraleitende
Magnete, wo wir 8,3 Tesla Magnetfelder erzeugen können, die mit konventionellen
Eisenmagneten nicht mehr erreichbar sind.
Also das mit dem Ring ist ja eigentlich eine ganz pfiffige Nummer,
weil sonst müsste man es ja quasi einmal um die Erde schicken,
wäre auch ganz schön, wäre ein echt toller Ring, aber kriegt man irgendwie nicht so richtig gebaut.
Heißt aber auch, wenn man es einmal in den Ring reinschickt,
dann möchte man es ja auch irgendwann aus dem Ring wieder rauskriegen,
da gibt es ja dann sozusagen eine Kreuzung, da muss ja dann irgendwo auch mal
eine Weiche gestellt werden und vor allem, vielleicht kannst du uns auch gleich
mal so ein Gefühl für die Zeit geben, in der sich das jetzt alles abspielt.
Also klar das Teilchen kommt aus dem Linearbeschleuniger, das macht halt zack,
dann ist es halt irgendwie schon in diesem Synchrotron.
Wie lange dauert das jetzt bis man das auf die gewünschte erste Zwischengeschwindigkeit bekommt?
Ist das dann auch nur zack und dann war's oder reden wir von Sekunden?
Sekunden, Sekunden in dem Fall. Also wir sprechen da immer von einer sogenannten
Basic Period, das ist so quasi der Herzschlag aller unserer Beschleuniger, das ist 1,2 Sekunden.
Alle 1,2 Sekunden kann unser erster Beschleuniger, erster Synchrotron der Booster
eben Strahl liefern an entweder eins der Experimente, das direkt an dem Booster
dran hängt oder an die nächsten Beschleuniger in der Kette.
Und innerhalb dieser 1,2 Sekunden passiert jetzt eben, dass der LINAC injiziert.
Danach werden die Teilchen beschleunigt, also das Magnetfeld im Booster wird
nach oben gefahren, bis wir von der Injektionsenergie von 160 MeV auf 2 GeV kommen.
An diesem Punkt würden dann die Strahlen aus der Maschine extrahiert werden,
zu der nächsten Maschine zum Beispiel. Und danach muss natürlich das Magnetfeld
auch wieder runtergefahren werden, damit man bereit ist für die nächste Injektion.
Und das nennen wir einen magnetischen Zyklus.
Injektion, Extraktion, wieder runterfahren, vorbereiten für die nächste Injektion.
Und das passiert eben alle 1,2 Sekunden.
Und die Beschleuniger, die dann dahinter stehen, Die können,
die Länge des magnetischen Zyklus kann im Prinzip ein Vielfaches dieser 1,2 Sekunden sein.
Die Rausführung ist dann sozusagen am Ende auch nur ein anders geschalteter
Magnet, der dann sozusagen das Teilchen nicht weiter in dieser Kreisbahn hält,
sondern einfach frei schießen lässt und dann schießt es einfach gerade rauf.
Wir nennen diese Elemente Kicker. Die kicken den Beam aus der Maschine raus.
Die sind im Prinzip schnelle Magnete, weil diese Dipole, die wir im Ring haben,
diese Hauptdipole, die ändern ihr Magnetfeld relativ langsam, über Millisekunden.
Also im Bereich von Millisekunden ändert man das Feld um, wir sprechen da von
Gauss, 10 hoch minus 4 Tesla.
Und dann sind das 10-20 Gauss, die sich da in der Millisekunde ändern.
Um den Strahl jetzt aber aus der Maschine zu extrahieren, wir sprechen da von
Umlaufzeiten, die im Mikrosekundenbereich sind. Das heißt viel schneller.
Deswegen braucht man schnell gepulste Magnete, eben diese Kicker,
die so ein, zwei Mikrosekunden lang ein Magnetfeld aufbauen und den Strahl wirklich
dann rauskicken, durch ein sogenanntes Septum.
Also im Ring selbst befindet sich so ein Kicker und dann geht der Strahl durch
ein Septum durch, das wiederum nichts anderes als ein Magnet ist,
das dazu führt, dass der Strahl dann ausgelenkt wird in die Transferlinie.
Okay, ich hätte jetzt vielleicht als erstes erstmal erwartet,
dass man einfach einen dieser Magneten, die das im Ring halten,
einfach ausschaltet und dann schießt das gerade aus, aber das ist nicht so,
weil die halt eben langsam sind und insofern dafür geeignet sind.
Das heißt man hat noch so einen zwischengeschalteten Kickermagneten,
der das daher einfach rausboxt.
Genau, es gibt viele zusätzliche Magnete in einem Beschleuniger.
Es gibt immer die Hauptdipole, es gibt die Hauptquadrupole, die eben für die
transversale Fokussierung da sind.
Es gibt die Hochfrequenzkapitäten, es gibt diese Kicker, es gibt die Scepter,
das sind eben diese Elemente zum Extrahieren direkt.
Es gibt Messinstrumente, man möchte wissen,
wie viel Intensität, wie viele Teilchen laufen um in meinem Ring,
welche Größe haben die, sprich ich kann die transversale Größe messen und viele
andere Elemente. Es gibt Positionen.
Wie viel ist da drin?
Mit einer Spule im Prinzip, die rundherum gewickelt ist, um deine Vakuumkammer.
Achso, weil das Teilchen da durchfliegt, dann erzeugt es natürlich einen Strom.
Genau, das nennen wir Beam Current Transformer. Also da wird einfach ein Strom
induziert, der der Anzahl der Teilchen proportional ist.
Und genauso kann man transversal die Größe messen des Strahls.
Das machen wir mit einem Draht, der durch den Strahl durchgeht,
sogenannter Wire Scanner.
Das heißt, der wird von links nach rechts oder oben nach unten durch den Strahl durchbewegt.
Dieser Draht ist eigentlich so ein Kohlenstoffdraht, die Teilchen kollidieren
mit diesem Kohlenstoffdraht.
Wird dann dazu geführt, dass Sekundärteilchen erzeugt werden.
Die werden von einem Sintellator gemessen, das wird verstärkt und das Signal
ist dann proportional zur Größe deines Strahls. Und du kannst sagen,
okay, dieser Strahl in den kleineren Maschinen ist vielleicht einen Zentimeter groß.
Im LHC, wenn es dann wirklich sehr klein wird, dann ist er halt ein paar hundert Mikrometer groß.
Eben Durchmesser?
Genau. Das ist nämlich auch ein wesentlicher Punkt. Je höher die Energie ist,
umso kleiner werden die Dimensionen der Teilchen.
Dementsprechend hat man auch bei den ersten Beschleunigern Vakuumkammern,
die extrem groß sind, weil diese Strahlen halt noch sehr divergent sind.
Und da reden wir von ein paar Zentimetern.
Dies können schon mal so sein, so 15 Zentimeter in der horizontalen Richtung
und 7, 8 Zentimeter in der vertikalen Richtung.
Während dann im LHC die Kammer halt wesentlich kleiner ist und hat dann nur
einen Durchmesser von so 4 Zentimetern ungefähr.
Aber nicht die Teilchen selber sind kleiner, sondern der Strahl in dem sie gebündelt sind ist kleiner.
Also im Prinzip der Leerraum zwischen den Teilchen verschwindet.
Ok, verstehe.
Ok, also wir haben jetzt die Quelle gehabt, wir haben die lineare Beschleunigung
gehabt, dort ging es ins Synchrotron rein, dann hat man 1,2 Sekunden Zeit das
mal ordentlich in Rotation zu bringen.
Das wird mit diesen langsamen Magneten, also verhältnismäßig langsamen Magneten
gemacht und dann mit dem Kicker werden sie raus aus ihrer Flugbahn ein wenig abgelenkt,
um dann von diesem Septum Element, was macht denn das überhaupt?
Ist wieder im Prinzip ein Dipole, ein schnell gepulster Genuss.
Also nochmal ein Magnet.
Nochmal ein Magnet.
Aber reicht der Kicker alleine nicht schon? Ich meine, wenn er kickt,
dann fliegt das doch schon woanders hin. Wozu braucht man dann noch einen?
Dann fliegt es woanders hin, aber man muss in der Maschine, muss man sich vorstellen,
aus dem einerseits den zirkulierenden Strahl hat.
Und dann hat man den extrahierten Strahl. Wenn dieses Septum jetzt im Zentrum
der Maschine sein würde, würde dort der zirkulierende Strahl sich bewegen und
der Strahl würde im Prinzip jedes Mal aus der Maschine ausgelenkt werden.
Aus dem Grund ist dieser Septum-Magnet mit einigem Abstand zum Zentrum der Maschine,
also ein paar Zentimeter außerhalb, installiert.
Dann verwendet man den Kicker, dass der Beam von der zentralen,
idealen Orbit eben ausgelenkt wird
und dann in die Öffnung von diesem Septum hineingetroffen wird und nur dort
sieht der Strahl dann wirklich das Magnetfeld von dem Septum,
so dass der zirkulierende Strahl während dieser ganzen 1,2 Sekunden nie von
diesem Feld, das in dem Septum wirkt, beeinflusst wird.
Und erst dann, wenn der Strahl zu hohen Amplituden gekickt wurde,
dann sieht der Strahl dort das Magnetfeld, wird ausgelenkt und dann geht es
weiter in der Transferlinie.
Okay, also weiter in der Transferlinie.
Was folgt denn auf dieses Synchrotron? Gibt es da nur eins von oder hat jeder
Linearbeschleuniger sein eigenes?
Da gibt es ein paar. Das ist eben die Beschleunigerkette. Es gibt einen Linearbeschleuniger,
dann gehen wir in einen Proton-Synchrotron-Booster, von dort gehen wir in das
Protonen-Synchrotron, dann in das Super-Protonen-Synchrotron und dann in den LAC.
Okay, also es gibt im Prinzip eine Kaskade von mehr oder weniger ähnlich aufgebauten
Dingern, die aber unterschiedliche Größen, andere Magnete, andere Dimensionierungen
haben und dabei immer wieder die Energie weiter steigern.
Genau, so Pi mal Dormen ist so ein Faktor 10 Energieerhöhung pro Maschine möglich.
Okay, wie groß sind diese einzelnen Synchrotrone dann so im Durchmesser?
Also der Booster hat einen Radius von 25 Metern mit einer Länge von 157 Metern,
der PS 628 Meter Länge, SPS 7 Kilometer und LAC dann 27 Kilometer Länge.
Und zum Beispiel, wenn man sich den PS hernimmt mit einem Radius von 100 Metern
und den Proton-Synchrotron-Booster mit einem Radius von 25 Metern,
da sieht man genau da, dass da eben ein Faktor 4 dazwischen ist,
weil in den Anfängen des ZERNs gab es den LINAK, der direkt in den PS injiziert hatte.
Und zwischen dann irgendwann in den 70er Jahren, um die Energie zu boosten,
wurde der Booster dazwischen geschaltet.
Und der hat dann eben dazu geführt, dass die Strahlen, die in den PS injiziert
werden, höhere Energie haben, als sie ursprünglich vom Linnak hatten.
Und das erlaubt einem höhere Strahldichten zu erzeugen, also mehr Teilchen in
kleinerer Fläche, um dann effizientere Experimente durchführen zu können.
So, das waren jetzt vier Synchrotrone, die wir aufgezählt haben.
Ganz genau.
Aber der Booster gehört jetzt nicht dazu?
Doch, doch. Booster, PS, SPS und LAC.
Okay, Booster, PS, SPS, LRC. Jetzt kriegst du langsam auf die Kette hier im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Und es folgt auch nur noch Synchrotron auf Synchrotron, also die Verbindung
ist sozusagen dann unmittelbar.
Vom Booster fliegt es auch direkt in den nächsten Ring rein.
Jeder dieser Beschleuniger hat zusätzlich seine experimentelle Zone,
Experimental Area nennen wir das, wo genauso Physikexperimente durchgeführt werden.
Also einerseits kann der Strahl zur nächsten Maschine kommen,
andererseits kann der Strahl zu diesen Experimenten direkt ausgelenkt werden.
Für Experimente, die jetzt nicht so viel Energie brauchen.
Ganz genau, ganz genau. Gibt es verschiedenste. Eben je nach Energiebedarf sind
sie dann an einem anderen Beschleuniger angesiedelt Und die nennt man Fixed
Target Experimente, sprich man schießt den Strahl auf ein feststehendes Ziel,
ein Metallblock in der Regel, und dahinter werden sekundäre Strahlen erzeugt.
Und je nachdem welches Experiment dort angeordnet ist, filtert es dann die Sekundärteilchen aus, Die,
benützt werden für das jeweilige Experiment und macht dann damit weitere Untersuchungen
oder der Strahl geht eben weiter zum nächsten Beschleuniger,
wo einfach die Energie erhöht wird und dann geht es weiter zum nächsten oder
eben zu der anderen Experimental Area.
Das kann man sozusagen je nach Experimentbedarf entsprechend timen,
dass man weiß so hier jetzt muss man da was machen und jetzt brauchen wir es in dem großen,
Es ist nicht so, dass nur eine dieser Konstellationen gleichzeitig funktionieren kann,
sondern die werden sozusagen die ganze Zeit alle parallel bedient,
dass es mehr oder weniger gleichzeitig, nebenläufig funktionieren kann.
Ganz genau, das ist relativ flexibel. Also wir haben diese 1,2 Sekunden,
in denen der Boosterstrahl produzieren kann,
dann geht der Strahl zum Beispiel zum PS weiter und kann dort innerhalb von
1,2 Sekunden wiederum extrahiert werden, ausgelenkt zu einem der Experimente.
Zum Beispiel gibt es EntOF, Neutron Time of Flight, wo Neutronenphysik gemacht wird.
Oder, es ist nicht immer im PS dann 1,2 Sekunden, manchmal muss man auch um
die Energie weiter zu erhöhen, 2,4 Sekunden oder 3,6 Sekunden machen.
Also diese Basic Period von 1,2 Sekunden einfach zusammenpacken in längere magnetische Zyklen.
Und dann kann man Strahl weiter senden zum Beispiel zu unserer Antimaterie Maschine,
dem Antiproton Decelerator oder zum Superprotonen Synchrotron,
wo dann im weiteren die Strahlen zum LAC.
Für den LHC produziert werden, aber das geht eben relativ flexibel.
Also einmal gibt es einen Strahl für ENTOF, einmal gibt es einen Strahl für
AD, einmal gibt es einen Strahl zum SPS.
Danach hat wieder nur der Booster Strahl und schickt das zu seiner Facility,
die ist die Isolde Facility, wo Isotope und exotische Atomkerne untersucht werden.
Und das ist relativ flexibel und all das wird immer und wieder abgespielt in
einer Konstellation, die wir Super Cycle nennen.
Also man hat zum Beispiel eine Programmierung von 20 verschiedenen magnetischen Zyklen,
die werden abgespeichert, da gibt es das Haupt-Timing-System,
das ist dafür zuständig, dass all diese Dinge eben der Reihe nach abgespielt
werden und nach 30 Sekunden beginnt es wieder vom Neuen und die gleichen User
bekommen wiederum ihren Strahl.
Das heißt, was bei uns wichtig ist, ist dann der sogenannte Duty-Cycle,
wie viel Strahl bekommt welches Experiment zu welchem Zeitpunkt.
Und das ist halt ein bisschen ein Verhandlungsgeschick im Hintergrund und da
gibt es natürlich gibt es da vom CERN Council dann auch Prioritäten,
welche Experimente sollten wie viel Strahlzeit bekommen über das Jahr verteilt.
Dann gibt es den Physikkoordinator, der sich dafür dann einsetzt,
dass die Interessen der Experimente richtig vertreten werden.
Und gemeinsam mit der Operation entwickelt man dann eben so ein Schema,
wie man diesen Beschleunigerkomplex betreibt, sodass im Endeffekt jeder glücklich wird.
Also vergleichbar mit so der Zuteilung von Beobachtungszeit auf Weltraumteleskopen,
wo sich ja auch mal alle boxen, wer denn jetzt mal wann wohin gucken kann.
Aber das lässt sich ja hier ganz gut aufteilen zumindest. Aber irgendwann ist
natürlich dann auch jeder Strahl vergeben und dann geht's los das Geboxe.
Stimmt ja.
Was sind denn exotische Atomkerne?
Gibt es welche, die so ein bisschen aus der Mode gekommen sind oder die nicht
so oft angeschaut werden?
Ja vor allem die sehr kurzlebig sind. Das sind dann Teilchen,
die wirklich unter Lava-Bedingungen erzeugt werden, die dann sehr kurzlebig
sind, oft sehr schwer sind und dann gibt es eben die Isolde-Facility,
die sich damit genauer dann beschäftigt und ansieht, wie sich diese Teilchen verhalten.
Diese vier Synchrotrone sind ja vermutlich auch alle mehr oder weniger in der
Reihenfolge gebaut worden. Mit dem kleinsten hat es mal angefangen und dann
ist man immer größer geworden, bis es halt jetzt bis zu dem LHC gekommen ist.
Und es gibt ja auch schon Pläne für noch größere Ausdehnungen.
Sind denn die technischen Unterschiede
dieser 4 Synchrotoner dürften wahrscheinlich auch signifikant sein?
Also einerseits, also das Prinzip ist immer das gleiche, aber die konkrete Ausführung ist anders.
Genau, also die Art und Weise dieser Hauptmagnete.
Die ändert sich von Maschine zu Maschine. Im Booster, im PS und im SPS verwenden
wir eben immer noch normal leitende Magnete, während im LAC dann supra leitende
Magnete verwendet werden.
Die Energie, die maximale Energie, die man erreichen kann in einer Maschine,
hängt eben ab von dem maximalen Magnetfeld, das man erreichen kann und von dem
Durchmesser der Maschine.
Dementsprechend braucht man, um zu den höchsten Energien zu kommen, große Tunnel.
Warum ist denn der Durchmesser entscheidend? Man könnte doch im Prinzip sagen,
man kann sich die ganze Zeit im Kreis drehen, wird immer schneller.
Aber irgendwann, das ist eben das Prinzip des Synchrotrons, sie werden immer
energetischer und energetischer, wenn das Magnetfeld nicht mehr mitfahren kann,
dann kannst du sie irgendwann nicht mehr auf der Kreisbahn halten.
Und deswegen mit normalen Leitungen.
Man muss die Krümmung reduzieren, damit man es überhaupt noch halten kann,
trotz höherer Energien.
Ganz genau. Und wenn wir dann vielleicht ein bisschen zur Supraleitung gehen, zum LHC.
Das ist nur dort so.
Es gibt verschiedenste kleinere Installationen, wo einzelne Magnete supraleitend
sind am CERN, aber wirklich am LHC sind die Hauptmagnete wirklich supraleitend.
Also da gibt es 1232 Dipole, die installiert sind. Jeder ist 15 Meter lang und die sind supraleitend.
Sprich, da ist nicht mehr das Eisen dafür zuständig,
dass die magnetische Feldlinienverteilung vorgegeben wird, sondern diese supraleitenden
Kabel, die im Inneren der Dipole angeordnet sind, sind auf eine bestimmte Art
und Weise angeordnet, dass eben ein Dipolemagnetfeld entsteht.
Und um in diesen supraleitenden Zustand zu kommen, muss man die Magnete kühlen.
Weil im Falle vom LAC wird er betrieben bei minus 271 Grad Celsius bei 1,9 Kelvin.
Diese Kabel, die da verwendet werden, sind aus Niobium-Titan,
die unterhalb einer bestimmten Temperatur superleitend werden,
was eben heißt, dass sie ihren elektrischen Widerstand verlieren und dass hohe
Ströme, so wie im LHC, bis zu 12.000,
Ampere, ungehindert fließen können. Aber dafür muss diese Superleitung permanent
aufrechterhalten werden.
Was heißt, diese Magnete müssen mit flüssigem Helium gekühlt werden,
um eben auf 1,9 Kelvin Arbeitstemperatur gehalten zu werden.
Da kann man sich schon vorstellen, dass da eine riesige Infrastruktur dahinter
steckt, um dieses Helium zur Verfügung zu stellen, abzukühlen,
in die Magnete zu bringen und die Magnete runter zu kühlen.
Ist flüssiges Helium nicht auch so total ätzend, dass man das überhaupt im Tank
behält? Also das kriecht doch auch überall durch, oder?
Es gibt dann natürlich, wir sprechen da von einer Cold Mass,
das ist jener Teil des Magneten, der kalt ist, der gekühlt wird.
Und der muss natürlich bestens abgeschirmt sein gegenüber der Außenwelt.
Das ist dann in seinem sogenannten Kryostat.
Da gibt es eine riesige Infrastruktur für die Kryotechnik.
Und man muss natürlich aufpassen zwischen den Verbindungen der Magneten,
dass alles extrem dicht ist, dass dort das Helium dann auch nicht irgendwo entweichen kann.
Weil das tut es gerne, ne?
Ja, ich meine, es ist natürlich auch in unserem Interesse, es nicht entweichen zu lassen.
Das ist natürlich eine 150 Tonnen vom Helium sind am CERN gespeichert und in
Verwendung, rein für den LHC. Das ist natürlich ein riesiger Speicher,
der auch einiges dann an Geld bindet, sag ich mal.
Und dementsprechend muss man da wirklich effizient sein, dass das wiederverwendet wird.
Aber wodurch wird diese Kühlung realisiert?
Also Helium muss ja erstmal gekühlt werden, das ist ja nur das Übertragungsmedium an der Stelle.
Da gibt es eben in dieser Kryotechnik verschiedene Kompressoren und Wärmetauscher
und Stickstoff vor allem, der als erste Kühlstufe dient, um die Maschine dann
runter zu kühlen bis zu 80 Kelvin.
Und ab dann erst übernimmt das Helium auch die weitere Kühltätigkeit, sage ich mal.
Und es ist vor allem, wenn man
sich denkt, dass man diese Maschine von Raumtemperatur runterkühlen muss,
minus 270 auf minus
270 grad dann kommt es dann natürlich auch zu
extremen mechanischen änderungen also
im endeffekt verkürzt sich so eine lhc magnet beim abkühlen um bis zu vier zentimeter
der ist wie groß normalerweise der ist eben so 15 meter lang 15 meter und wird
vier zentimeter also über die ganze maschine sprechen wir da schon von mehr
als 50 metern dann ja und das muss ausgeglichen werden,
auch von diesen Flanschen oder Bellows,
die flexibel gestaltet werden müssen zwischen den verschiedenen Magneten,
damit dort diese Längendilatation abgefangen werden kann.
Wann ist der LHC das erste Mal in Betrieb gegangen?
Das erste Mal in Betrieb gegangen ist der 2008 und dann gab es einen kleinen Stopp 2008 bis 2009.
Weil mit dem Magneten was schief gelaufen ist?
Genau, da ist in der ersten Phase, während einer Testphase ein bisschen was schief gelaufen.
Da warst du aber noch nicht hier oder? Da war ich noch nicht hier. Ich bin seit 2011 hier.
Aber da gab es einen, im Prinzip gab es einen elektrischen Kurzschluss in der
Verbindung zweier Magnete.
Ja.
Das hat dazu geführt, dass es dann einen Lichtbogen gab, der genau diese Verpackung
des Heliums dann mal durchtrennt hat.
Das Helium dann begonnen hat dort auszutreten und eigentlich sind die Magnete,
haben schon Sicherheitsvorkehrungen dafür eingebaut, dass sowas passiert.
Aber das waren einfach Unmengen von Helium, die da ausgetreten sind.
Diese ganzen Ventile, die da existieren, die waren nicht dafür ausgelegt.
Und dementsprechend hat es dann eine riesige Druckwelle in der Maschine gegeben,
als dieses flüssige Helium dann gasförmig geworden ist, durch diese Ventile austreten wollte.
Der Druck hat sich immer weiter aufgebaut in diesem Kryostaten.
Und dann hat es einfach dazu geführt, dass longitudinal entlang der Maschine
eine extreme Druckwelle sich ausgebreitet hat und große Teile der Maschine einfach zerstört hat.
Und da mussten dann auch so bis zu 50 Magnete ausgetauscht werden,
was dann zu einem Stopp von einem Jahr geführt hat. Das Sicherheitssystem wurde
überdacht und seitdem laufen wir dann auch wieder ohne Probleme.
Also gebrannt hat er aber nichts. Nein, gebrannt hat er nichts.
So eine reine mechanische Deformation, aber das ist ja auch schlimm genug bei diesen Geräten.
Die kauft man ja auch nicht so von der Stange, die werden ja auch alle speziell
dafür hergestellt. und da gab es dann wahrscheinlich auch keine mehr,
die noch irgendwie auf Lager lagen.
Es gab da zum Glück noch Ersatzterrenner und Ersatzmagnete, absolut.
Glück gehabt.
Glück im Unglück, das sagt gern.
Ok, haben wir denn jetzt die Chain mehr oder weniger komplett?
Wenn wir jetzt mal so die ganze Beschleunigung vielleicht noch mal kurz zusammenfassen
von der Quelle geht es durch den Linearbeschleuniger und da waren wir schon
bei den Megaelektronenvolt oder waren das noch die Kilowatt?
160 Megaelektronenvolt und dann gehen wir in den Booster,
da gehen wir zu 2 Gigaelektronenvolt, im Protonensynchrotron zu 26 Gigaelektronenvolt,
im Superprotonensynchrotron zu 450 Gigaelektronenvolt Und dann schlussendlich
im LHC zu 7 Teraelektronenvolt oder 7000 Gigaelektronenvolt Energie pro Strahl.
Weil im LHC kollidieren wir zwei Strahlen aufeinander.
Das heißt, vom SPS gibt es zwei Transferlinien, die einmal BIM1 und BIM2 in den LHC injizieren.
Einmal läuft der Strahl im Uhrzeigersinn, einmal gegen den Uhrzeigersinn,
in zwei unabhängigen Vakuumkammern.
Und an den Interaktionspunkten, wo dann die großen Experimente angeordnet sind,
dort werden die Strahlen dann vereint in eine einzelne Vakuumkammer und in Kollision gebracht.
Diese Strahlen sind jetzt nicht kontinuierlich in der Maschine,
die sind in Pakete zusammengefasst, die nennen wir Bunches.
Particle-Proton-Bunches und im LHC haben diese Pakete 25 Nanosekunden Abstand.
Also alle 25 Nanosekunden haben wir so ein Paket und insgesamt können wir so
2800 dieser Pakete in der Maschine Speichern.
Und in Kollision bringen.
Speichern heißt im Ring behalten.
Im Ring behalten, weil das ist auch diese 1,2 Sekunden, über die wir gesprochen
haben, diese Basic Period, die trifft nicht wirklich auf den LHC zu.
Der LHC ist einerseits eine Kollisionsmaschine, die eben Teilchen kollidieren
lässt, aber andererseits auch ein sogenannter Speicherring, der die Protonenstrahlen
über Stunden speichern kann.
Sprich die ganze Injektorenkette, die die sendet Strahl zum LHC,
die füllt den LHC mit der Anzahl an Teilchen, Anzahl an Protonenpakete, die der LHC benötigt.
Sobald dieses Füllen abgeschlossen ist, beginnt der LHC die Energie zu erhöhen
von den 450 GeV Injektionsenergie hoch auf diese 7 Teraelektronenvolt.
Und danach beginnt man so eine Phase, in der verschiedene Maschinenparameter
angepasst werden, um möglichst effizient nachher in Kollision gehen zu können.
Und dann erst beginnt man Physik und das nennen wir dann Stable Beams,
wenn die Strahlen eben stabil kollidieren und das kann mehrere Stunden dauern.
Also der Rekord, dass die Strahlen im LHC gehalten wurden,
sind um die 56 Stunden und so ein typischer Fill,
also typische Dauer dieser Stable Beams ist so 8 bis 12 Stunden,
in denen Kollisionen stattfinden, in denen die Direktoren dann die Kollisionsprodukte
messen und langsam stetig nimmt dann die Teilchenanzahl in der Maschine ab,
bis irgendwann nicht mehr genügend Teilchen vorhanden sind und dann wird die
Maschine eben neu gefüllt.
Das heißt man, ich hab mir das glaube ich am Anfang so ein bisschen vorgestellt,
für jede Kollision pumpt man einmal da so einen Strahl rein und dann ballert
der anderthalb Sekunden später halt irgendwo drauf und das war's.
Und wenn man wieder weitermachen will holt man sich halt einfach das nächste aus der Quelle.
Das ist halt ineffizient weil diese Rampe um von 450 GeV auf 7 Teraelektronen
Volt zu kommen im LHC schon mal eine halbe Stunde dauert.
Aha, das wäre meine nächste Frage gewesen, wie lange das eigentlich dauert.
Eine halbe Stunde bis man auf die maximale Geschwindigkeit kommt.
Genau, bis man auf die maximale Energie ist.
Das heißt, wie viel davon wird in den einzelnen der vier Ringe drauf verwendet?
Dieses Füllen, das dauert ungefähr eine halbe Stunde.
Oder sind die alle im Prinzip gleichzeitig im Betrieb, die Ringe?
Die sind alle immer gleichzeitig in Betrieb. Die Strahlen für den LAC werden
durch die komplette Kette durchgesendet, in den LAC injiziert.
Aber wir können immer nur eine bestimmte Anzahl von Teilchenpaketen erzeugen in den Injektoren.
Sprich, wir brauchen viele Injektionen in den LAC von einer bestimmten Anzahl an Teilchenpaketen.
Jetzt sagt man zum Beispiel, wir injizieren 144 Pakete von dem SPS in den LAC.
Wir wollen im Endeffekt 2800 haben.
Dementsprechend muss man diese Injektionen und diesen Prozess immer und immer
wieder wiederholen, bis der LHC schlussendlich voll ist und erst wenn der LHC
komplett gefüllt ist, dann beginnt der LHC sein Energiereinschub.
Also der wird sozusagen so richtig Druck betankt und so voll gemacht wie es irgendwie geht.
Und was ist die Grenze dafür, wieviel Teilchen der aufnehmen kann und von was
für einer Menge an Masse reden wir da?
Also so ein Protonen-Bunch, der hat 10 hoch 11 Teilchen.
Also sind wir so bei 100 Milliarden Teilchen in einem solchen Bunch und dann
hat man 2000 die da drinnen zirkulieren.
Ist nicht viel. Ist nicht viel.
Also nicht dass da jetzt Kilogramm Material rumfliegt, sondern eigentlich eher sehr sehr wenig.
Aber energetisch ist es extrem viel. Also die Energie, die in so einem Strahl
gespeichert ist, vor allem bei der höchsten Energie im LHC, bei 7 TeV,
die ist schon wirklich enorm.
Und einerseits hängt das natürlich ab von der Ladung der Protonen,
einerseits von der Anzahl der Teilchen, von der Anzahl der Bunche.
Und da kann man dann schon sagen, dass wir so 500 Megajoule an Energie in einem
Strahl speichern, was dann auch gefährlich für die Maschine werden kann.
500 Megajoule kann man so eine Tonne Kupfer schmelzen.
Wir machen oft den Vergleich so ein Hochgeschwindigkeitszug bei über 200 Kilometer
pro Stunde hat ungefähr die gleiche gespeicherte Energie.
Also kann man sich schon vorstellen, wenn der einen Unfall baut, was damit passiert.
Ein Güterzug.
Obwohl es sich quasi unbeschleunigt nur um wenige Gramm handeln würde sozusagen.
Also die Masse ist nicht das Problem, es ist wirklich die Energie.
Ja klar, die Masse entsteht ja dann durch die Energie, ist ja letztlich das gleiche.
Und diese Speicherung, gerade mit dem Beispiel,
das war auch mal, was weiß ich, über zwei Tage da drin,
das heißt, wenn man es einmal so beschleunigt hat mit diesen supraleitenden
Magneten, Muss man dann auch nicht so viel Energie wieder hinzuführen,
um das am Laufen zu halten oder muss das im Prinzip die ganze Zeit angetrieben werden?
Die Energie, die man braucht, ist jene,
um das Helium kühl zu halten und um diese ganze Kryo-Anlage im Betrieb zu halten.
Aber dann genau, dann haben wir keine resistiven Verluste, keinen Widerstand
in den Spulen. Da zirkulieren die 11.000, 12.000 Ampere durch die Maschine.
Weil es ja Supraleitend ist, also Hauptsache es ist kühl, aber die Kühlmaschinen,
die fressen natürlich auch nochmal.
Absolut. Trotzdem haben wir im LHC dann einen konstanten Verbrauch von 40 Megawatt.
40 Megawatt konstanter Verbrauch, solange der Ring in Betrieb ist.
Ganz genau. Und wie oft, also ist der immer in Betrieb?
Gerade heute haben wir im Prinzip, oder gestern, die Commissioning-Phase vom LRC abgeschlossen.
Sprich, er ist jetzt wirklich in den Physikbetrieb übergegangen und beginnt
jetzt langsam mit der Intensität und der Anzahl der Protonenpakete nach oben zu gehen.
Das ist immer so ein, der Anfang des Jahres muss man immer wieder checken,
dass wirklich alle Systeme richtig funktionieren und dass man dann langsam die
Intensität, die in der Maschine gespeichert wird, nach oben dreht,
bis man eben dort ankommt, wo wir dann so gegen Ende Juni bis Ende des Jahres laufen.
Und dann gibt es diese Winterstops, Wintershutdowns,
und die sind dieses Jahr zum Beispiel von Ende Oktober Bis dann nächstes Jahr
Februar, März, wo die Maschinen dann graduell wieder ans Netz gebracht werden.
Vor allem im Winter, wenn auch der Strom relativ teuer ist, wird gestoppt.
Deswegen?
Auch deswegen, absolut.
Aber nicht nur deswegen?
Naja, einerseits braucht man natürlich Wartungsarbeiten, die jedes Jahr durchgeführt werden müssen,
aber gerade auch mit den aktuellen Strompreisen und mit eventuellen Engpässen
in der Stromlieferung und so stoppen wir auch früher, als wir normalerweise getan hätten.
Also zum Beispiel dieses Jahr wird ein Jahr früher gestoppt,
eben auch aus Energieeffizienzgründen.
Und während dieser ganzen Zeit verbraucht der LAC diese 40 Megawatt und erst
dann wirklich im Winter, wenn er abgeschaltet wird, dann geht dieser Verbrauch nach unten.
Verstehe. Also der Grund,
dass es abgeschaltet wird ist, man muss sowieso warten und man macht es dann
am besten im Winter, weil dann spart man auch noch am meisten Strom und dann
haben manche auch noch ein bisschen Pause und man macht ja lieber einen Urlaub
im Winter. Okay, verstehe.
Kommt das eine und das andere zusammen.
Eigentlich wollen doch alle nur Skifahren gehen.
Gibt es hier eine gute Infrastruktur. Hab ich auch gehört.
Jetzt hast du erwähnt, es gibt ja diverse Punkte,
an denen man, also sozusagen immer am Ausgang der kleineren Synchrotrone,
da gibt es sozusagen die Möglichkeit Experimente zu fahren.
Im reinen Kollisionsmodus, also sozusagen die Teilchen die beschleunigt sind
die treffen dann auf irgendwas auf, dieses Prinzip mit zwei Strahlen treffen
aufeinander, das ist sozusagen LHC spezifisch, das geht nur in dem großen Ring.
Jetzt gibt es ja glaube ich noch so eine Sonderzone, wo so Experimente aller Art angesiedelt sind.
Die North Zone oder die East Zone. North ist am SPS,
East ist am PS, wo dann verschiedene User,
wie wir die nennen, von außen hineinkommen können und verschiedenste Tests machen können,
also zum Beispiel Materialien einfach bestrahlen, um zu sehen,
wie sich die unter der Einwirkung von Protonenstrahlen oder Ionenstrahlen verhalten.
Oder wirklich auch Grundlagenforschung zu machen, um sich anzusehen,
wie zerfallen verschiedene Produkte, was sind die Zerfallsprodukte.
Also einerseits gerade zum Beispiel dunkle Materie,
natürlich einerseits gibt es die Forschung dafür am LHC,
aber es gibt auch sehr viel Forschung in diesen ganzen experimentellen Zonen,
wo man halt, nachdem die Möglichkeit der Masse dieser Teilchen,
die zuständig sein können für die dunkle Materie, einen enormen Energiebereich
spannen können, man nicht genau weiß, wo, in welchem Energiebereich sich die
befinden, sucht man im LHC danach, sucht man aber auch bei anderen Energien danach einfach.
Und dafür sind diese verschiedenen Beschleuniger mit ihren unterschiedlichen
Energien wirklich bestens geeignet, wenn man verschiedene Experimente an verschiedenen
Beschleunigern durchführen kann. Was jetzt das...
Was der Unterschied ist zwischen diesen Kollisionsexperimenten und diesen Fixed-Target-Experimenten
ist, dass die Energien, die erreicht werden können, wesentlich geringer sind bei Fixed-Target.
Man schießt den umlaufenden Strahl auf einen ruhenden Block.
Da ist im Prinzip die Energie, die man erzeugt proportional zur Wurzel aus der
Energie der einfallenden Teilchen,
während bei den zwei umlaufenden Strahlen einfach die doppelte Energie,
die Energie jedes Strahles zählt und somit haben wir diese Kollisionen bei 7 TeV.
Das führt zu einer Schwerpunktenergie von 14 TeV in beiden Strahlen und man
hat halt viel mehr Energie zur Verfügung, die man in Materie umwandeln kann,
als bei diesen Fixed-Target-Experimenten.
Ok, Grundlagenforschung ist klar, das ist immer interessant und das steht ja
hier auch im Fokus. Aber es gibt auch andere Forschungen. Was ist das?
Also Materialforschung, dass man in dem Bereich so einen Strahlenbeschleuniger auch benutzen kann?
Also wir haben zum Beispiel, wenn ich als Beispiel hernehme,
die East Area am PS, dann gibt es dort eine sogenannte Test Facility und die
wird auch dafür verwendet, dass all die großen LHC-Experimente, ATLAS, CMS, LS etc.
Ihre Detektoren testen können und sehen, wie sich die Materialien,
wie sich die Siliziumdetektoren verhalten unter Strahleinfluss.
Also in diesem Sinne auf jeden Fall auch Materialtests für zukünftige Entwicklungen
der verschiedenen Bestandteile der Kette im Prinzip.
Dann gibt es auch eine Facility, die nennt sich Heiratmat, wo wir mit hohen
Energien auf Materialien, auf verschiedensten Materialien die Strahlen schießen.
Um dann eben einfach zu sehen, wie gut, wie, wie soll ich sagen,
wie widerstandsfähig sind verschiedenste Materialien.
Was für Schäden kann der Strahl erzeugen, abhängig von der Strahlgröße,
von der Strahlintensität, von der Strahlenergie.
Wenn wir verschiedenste Elemente im Beschleuniger einbauen, möchte man oft mal
neue Materialien ausprobieren und sehen, ob die vielleicht ein bisschen besser
geeignet sind für den jeweiligen Anwendungszweck. Das muss man vorher testen.
Und dafür gibt es dann so eine Facility zum Beispiel. Dann gibt's...
Unsere Antimaterie-Produktion mit dem Antiprotonen-Decelerator,
ein Endschleuniger, der dazu führt, dass Teilchen langsamer werden.
Also wie das dort funktioniert ist, man schießt wiederum Protonen auf einen
Metallblock und filtert dahinter die Antiprotonen heraus.
Das heißt, alle anderen Teilchen werden im Prinzip abgelenkt und weggeworfen,
wenn man so möchte. Man filtert nur die Antiprotonen heraus.
Die werden dann von einer speziellen weiteren Maschine, auch ein Synchrotron,
das halt nicht Teil der Hauptkette ist, aber genauso ein Synchrotron ist,
die werden von dort dann entschleunigt, zu einem weiteren kleinen Synchrotron geschickt vom AD,
diesem Decelerator, zu Eleanor, der eine sehr geringe Energie am Ende hat und
dort kommen wir zu antiprotonen Energien von nur 100 Kiloelektronenvolt.
Also da sind wir dann quasi wieder von den Energien vergleichbar zum Beginn
der Kette, wo wir die Protonen erzeugt haben.
Gerade mal in der Source.
Genau, aber man braucht eben hohe Energien zu formen,
die Antiprotonen zu erzeugen und dann möchte man sie aber extrem abbremsen,
um sie einerseits untersuchen zu können und Vergleiche machen zu können zwischen
Antiprotonen und Protonen.
Andererseits aber auch einfach um Antivasserstoff zu erzeugen.
Das heißt, man bringt diese Antiprotonen in Kontakt mit den Antiteilchen vom Elektron,
dem Positron, und versucht daraus ein Antivasserstoffatom zu erzeugen und untersucht
dann die Eigenschaften dieses Antivasserstoffs und vergleicht sie mit Wasserstoff.
Zum Beispiel die Energieniveaus, die so ein Antiwasserstoffatom mit sich bringt.
Wie verhält es sich in der Schwerkraft, falls nach oben oder falls nach unten?
Verhalten die sich denn sonst ähnlich wie ihre Äquivalente?
Ja, ja, ja.
Ich weiß ja nicht, ich habe nicht so viel mit Antimaterie zu tun.
Ist die jetzt hier gerade im Raum? Kann schon sein, ja?
Naja, das ist halt so eine der großen Fragen der Physik. Woher kommt dieses
Ungleichgewicht zwischen Materie und Antimaterie?
Ursprünglich, direkt nach dem Urknall geht man davon aus, dass ja beide irgendwie
zu gleichen Teilen bestanden haben müssen, aber die Materie hat dann gewonnen.
Wenn die beide wirklich identisch gewesen wären, dann löscht sich Materie und
Antimaterie einfach aus. Dann gäbe es vielleicht gar nichts.
Genau, aber wir sind immer noch da.
Also da gab es dann irgendeinen Mechanismus, der dann dazu geführt hat,
dass doch die Materie gewonnen hat.
Und das möchte man auch untersuchen mit diesen Antimaterien.
Das heißt die andere Antimaterie, die übrig geblieben ist, die ist vielleicht
schon längst egalisiert, also das ist alles weg, aber man kann es sozusagen
kurzfristig wiederherstellen?
Man kann sie erzeugen wieder genau.
Okay, verstehe. Jetzt geht ja nicht immer alles nach Plan.
Also wir hatten ja schon diesen kleinen Unfall, sowas erregt natürlich immer
viel Aufmerksamkeit, gerade wenn es neu ist, aber was treten denn hier für Probleme auf?
Also was geht denn auch mal schief oder was ist sozusagen das,
worauf auch die ganze Zeit geachtet werden muss?
Also Surveillance, Wartung und Reparaturen, was geht kaputt? Die Kühlung? Alles?
Viel.
Das ist permanent auch.
Ja, auch permanent. Es ist halt doch ein riesiger Komplex mit verschiedensten
Technologien, die im Einsatz sind. Mit verschiedensten Elementen.
Magneten, Stromversorgungen, Kühlsysteme, Vakuumsysteme, Hochfrequenzsysteme
und überall dort kann was kaputt gehen.
Das kann einfach ein Kondensator sein in einer der Stromversorgungen,
dass einer der Magnete dann einfach nicht mehr den Strom bekommt,
den er eigentlich braucht, um die Strahlen auf der Bahn halten zu können.
Dafür gibt es dann am CERN die Equipment-Experten.
Also für jeden Bereich gibt es im Prinzip die Experten.
Und wir in der Operations Group sind dafür zuständig. Wir haben Leute,
die 24-7 auf Schicht sind, um diese Beschleuniger zu betreiben und eben auch
die Leistungsfähigkeit der Maschine nachzuverfolgen.
Und immer wenn ein Problem auftritt, entweder selbst lösen zu können oder halt
auch zu identifizieren, welche Leute muss ich kontaktieren, um jetzt diese eine
Stromversorgung zum Beispiel zu reparieren.
Manchmal kann es sein, dass an einer Stelle zum Beispiel ein Problem mit dem Vakuum auftritt.
Dann kontaktiert man den Vakuum-Experten, der sich das dann genau ansieht und
uns sagt, okay, ist normal, erwarten wir, oder da haben wir vielleicht ein Lack,
sollten wir uns mal anschauen. dann müssen wir mal in die Maschine hinein und
das vielleicht patchen.
Dann, was wir gerade gestern wieder hatten, ein kritischer Punkt ist immer,
Strahl von einer Maschine in die andere Maschine rüber zu schicken,
weil man hat eben diese Kicker und man muss diese Kicker richtig timen,
dass der Kicker in der einen Maschine den Strahl extrahiert,
aber gleichzeitig gibt es in der anderen Maschine Kicker, die den Strahl injizieren.
Also Extraktionskicker, Injektionskicker, die müssen aber mehr oder weniger
gleichzeitig feuern, nur durch die Time of Flight, die die Teilchen halt brauchen,
von einer Maschine zur nächsten und die halt synchronisiert.
Und dafür gibt es einen ganzen Synchronisierungsmechanismus zwischen den Maschinen,
wo die eine Maschine Informationen zur anderen Maschine sendet und wenn da mal
ein Stück Hardware kaputt geht, dann kannst du auf einmal keine Strahlen mehr injizieren.
Krass die spielen so Tennis miteinander, im Prinzip die Maschinen und wieviel Sensoren?
Hat man dann so im Blick, also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es alles voll
ist mit Sensoren aller Art und dann hat man so einen Control Room,
so einen War Room, wo 30.000 Bildschirme hängen.
Ja ganz so viele sind es nicht, aber wir haben schon, auf jeden Fall wir haben
das CERN Control Center, den CCC, wo der Großteil aller Bioschleuniger kontrolliert wird.
Und da haben wir unsere Vistas, die Bildschirme an der Wand hängen,
die uns zu jeder Zeit Statusinformationen geben über die Beschleuniger selbst.
Was ist die Intensität im Beschleuniger? Was ist das Magnetfeld im Beschleuniger?
Welche Art von magnetischem Zyklus wird gerade gespielt? Wohin sollen diese
Teilchen geschickt werden?
Habe ich Verluste, weil es kann auch sein, wenn eines dieser Elemente dann nicht
funktioniert im Beschleuniger, dann werde ich es in erster Linie dadurch sehen,
dass ich irgendwo Strahlverluste habe.
Das kann soweit führen, dass ich einen Alarm bekomme, weil an einer bestimmten
Stelle der ganze Strahl zentriert einfach aus der Maschine rausgeschossen wurde,
wo aber jetzt nicht die Transferlinie unbedingt ist.
Dann kriege ich dort einen Alarm über unseren Radiation Monitor und dann muss
ich verstehen, welches Element nicht funktioniert und dazu geführt hat,
dass wir den Strahl dort eben verloren haben.
In größeren Maschinen ist das dann wirklich problematisch, weil dort eben die
gespeicherte Energie im Strahl so hoch ist, dass, wenn das passiert,
die Maschine beschädigt werden kann.
Dementsprechend braucht man da schon spezielle Maschinenschutzkonzepte,
die frühzeitig erkennen, ob irgendein Equipment fehlerhaft ist.
In den kleineren Maschinen bis zum PS ist das jetzt nicht so problematisch,
ab dem SPS wird das dann eben problematisch.
In den kleineren Maschinen kriegt man halt einen Alarm und muss dann ein bisschen
warten, bis dieses Strahlungsniveau im Prinzip runtergegangen ist.
Und dann nehmen wir den Betrieb wieder auf.
Und oftmals kommt es auch vor, dass man dann direkt in die Maschine hineingehen
muss, weil Sachen, die kaputt gegangen sind, wirklich im Ring selbst nur zu reparieren sind.
Und das können zum Beispiel Verstärker sein für diese Hochfrequenz-Kavitäten.
Die haben oft Verstärker, die sehr nahe am Beam gebaut sind,
damit die ganzen Kabellängen und dergleichen wesentlich ziemlich kurz sind.
Und da muss man dann, da haben wir eine eigene Strahlenschutzgruppe,
die kontaktiert man dann,
die sagen, okay ihr habt so und so viel Stahl produziert in den letzten so und so viele Stunden,
das heißt jetzt müssen wir dort 15 Minuten, 30 Minuten, eine Stunde warten,
bis wir überhaupt hineingehen können in die Maschine, damit die Leute,
die dort dann arbeiten, auch einfach nur eine minimale radioaktive Strahlendosis abbekommen.
Das ist nett, ja. Gab's denn auch mal so einen Fehler, wo ihr irgendwie nur
blöd geguckt habt und überhaupt nicht wusstet, was jetzt los ist?
So beginnt jeder Fehler.
Die Frage ist, wie lange hält der Zustand an?
Ja das kommt wirklich auf den Fehler drauf an. Gestern früh hatten wir da einen
Fehler, der eben die Synchronisation zwischen Booster und PS betroffen hat und
da haben wir so 3-4 Stunden mal herumgesucht, welches dieser Hardware-Module
denn kaputt gegangen ist.
Dann machst du ein Reboot von diesem Ding, dann funktionieren aber ein paar
der Parameter sind nicht richtig abgespeichert worden im Memory,
du musst sie neu setzen und es kann schon sein, dass das ein paar Stunden mal dauert.
Auch manchmal ist es halt nicht so offensichtlich welches Element jetzt der Schuldige ist.
Das wollte ich nämlich gerade sagen. Wenn man weiß wo das Problem ist,
ist man ja schon mal relativ weit.
Richtig, richtig. Oftmals weiß man nicht und dann versucht man halt auszuschließen,
was kann es nicht sein, bis man dann hinkommt und das eingrenzt.
Und natürlich was uns oft Hilfe gibt, ist der Strahl selbst.
Also wenn man den Strahl in die Maschine injizieren kann, aber dann zum Beispiel
in der Maschine nicht behalten kann, dann kann man den Strahl immer noch selbst
messen. Und man kann sich die Position des Strahls anschauen,
man kann sich die Größe des Strahls anschauen, man kann sich die Energie des Strahls anschauen.
Und das gibt dann oft auch einen Hinweis darauf, was schief geht.
Ist er zum Beispiel zu groß der Strahl, dann funktioniert irgendeiner von diesen
Quadrupolen nicht, dann funktioniert die Fokussierung nicht richtig.
Ist er viel zu lang der Strahl, ist er nicht mehr ein Paket,
sondern ist er so ein kontinuierlicher Strahl, dann sagen wir,
dass der Strahl debunched ist, ist eben kein Bunch mehr.
Dann funktioniert das mit den RF-Systemen nicht. Also so kann man sich mit dem
Strahl schon immer die Informationen holen, die man braucht,
um zumindest einzugrenzen, wo man sucht, ja.
Ich kenne das aus manchen Bereichen, wo in zunehmendem Maße so eine Maschinenüberwachung
auch mit Machine Learning schon gemacht wird,
dass man im Prinzip die Sensorik einfach die ganze Zeit irgendwie erlernt und
wenn man einen Fehler hat,
dann sagt man so, hier ist mal was kaputt gegangen, dass man quasi schon sich
so langsam so ein System aufbaut, was so Frühwarnfähigkeiten hat,
also quasi das Versagen von Sensoriken oder so gewisser Insicht vorher sagt.
Das ist das Stichwort preventive maintenance, also Wartung vorhersehen im Prinzip,
bevor sie notwendig wird und Teile austauschen.
Also wir haben Unmengen von Daten, die wir laufend abspeichern,
natürlich einerseits der Experimente, aber auch wir auf der Beschleunigerseite.
Wir haben wirklich ein System, das all diese Daten kontinuierlich lockt und
das einerseits über die Strahlqualität, aber andererseits auch über die Equipmentqualität.
Und diese Datenmenge, die können wir dann eben verwenden, um Modelle zu trainieren
und dann Vorhersagen zu machen.
Man steckt noch ein bisschen in den Kinderschuhen für jetzt gerade diese Wartungsvorhersagen,
aber wo wir viel Machine Learning oder Optimierung einfach verwenden,
ist, um die Leistungsfähigkeit des Strahls zu verbessern.
Es gibt Temperaturvariationen, im LHC gibt es zum Beispiel auch Einfluss der Gezeiten.
Das sieht man auch, die Maschine ist relativ sensibel darauf, wie der Mond steht.
Also die Parameter des Strahls können sich laufend ändern.
Da kann natürlich der Operator, der die Maschine betreibt, intervenieren und
verschiedene Parameter anpassen.
Das passiert dann alle x Minuten, Stunden oder dergleichen, je nachdem,
wie es erforderlich ist.
Oder wir verwenden Optimierungsalgorithmen, die kontinuierlich die Strahlparameter
überwachen Und immer dann, wenn so ein Drift gemerkt wird, nachkorrigieren.
Das hilft uns auch in vielen Teilen, die Leistungsfähigkeit unserer Strahlen
einfach immer auf optimalem Niveau zu halten, sage ich mal.
Das ist auf jeden Fall alles ein Moving Target. Es ist nicht einfach so eine Maschine,
die man mal einschalten, dann läuft sie halt, sondern man muss eigentlich die
ganze Zeit drauf schauen,
man muss die ganze Zeit optimieren, gucken, dass nichts kaputt geht oder sich
nicht zu schnell verschleißt und um sozusagen dann auch diesen Flow der Detektion,
der letzten Endes das Ziel der ganzen Operation ist, nicht abreißen zu lassen.
Trotzdem muss ja dann der Apparat ab und zu mal, also nicht nur gewartet werden,
sondern es gab ja auch diese längeren Auszeiten, ich glaub das waren jetzt zwei große.
2019, 20, da war der letzte große Stopp, Long Shutdown 2.
Davor gab es schon mal 2013, 14, gab es Long Shutdown 1 und jetzt für 26,
27, 28 ist dann Long Shutdown 3 geplant.
In den vergangenen zwei Jahren hat man sich darum gekümmert,
dass die LHC-Injektoren bessere Leistungsfähigkeit haben,
um sie vorzubereiten auf das Upgrade des LHC selbst, was 2026-2028 stattfinden
wird, mit dem Ziel, dass wir mehr Kollisionen erzeugen können.
Ein wesentlicher Parameter im LHC ist die Luminosität.
Die sagt uns, wie viele Kollisionen pro Sekunde und pro Fläche können wir erzeugen.
Das heißt, umso höher die Luminosität, umso höher die Anzahl der Kollisionen,
die wir den Experimenten zur Verfügung stellen können.
Und die Luminosität wird umso höher, je mehr Teilchen wir haben,
haben oder je kleiner die Fläche unserer Teilchenpakete ist.
Deswegen hat dieser vergangene Shutdown in den Injektoren dazu gedient,
diese Strahlparameter zu verbessern, sprich mehr Teilchen in kleinere Strahldimensionen
hineinpacken zu können.
Wir haben im Prinzip für die LHC-Strahlen die Anzahl der Teilchen verdoppelt
und die Fläche halbiert.
Und somit können wir dann wesentlich höhere Luminosität zur Verfügung stellen
für die verschiedenen LHC-Experimente.
Das war im Prinzip ein Upgrade-Programm, das rein ausgelegt war auf die Anforderungen
des zukünftigen LHC, also High-Luminosity-LHC heißt dann das Upgrade vom LHC in den nächsten Jahren.
Aber gleichzeitig ist das dann auch von Vorteil für alle anderen Experimente,
die am CERN stattfinden, weil genauso diese verbesserte Strahlqualität auch denen zugutekommt.
Also so kann man dann noch mehr rausholen aus dem LHC und dann wird ja,
wie lange ist die Pause? In so einem Jahr?
Drei Jahre für den LHC.
Drei Jahre?
Ja, wirklich große Umbauarbeiten sind da geplant. Da werden Teile der Magnete
ausgetauscht, da werden neue
Systeme eingebaut, um diese Kollisionen eben noch effizienter zu machen.
Und da braucht man dann doch einiges an Zeit, auch viel Arbeit passiert jetzt schon.
Also alles was Infrastruktur betrifft, alles was neue Gebäude,
neue Tunnelbereiche und so gibt, das wurde sogar schon alles fertiggestellt.
Aber jetzt natürlich, jetzt holen wir noch so viel wie möglich raus aus der
Maschine und warten auch noch bis die ganzen Bauteile dann wirklich zur Verfügung
stehen, um dieses Upgrade machen zu können.
Und dann wird die Maschine für drei Jahre abgeschaltet und abgegradet.
Das ist schon echt speziell, dass man so eine unglaublich lange Auszeit hat.
Für die Wissenschaftler stimmt das auch nicht so toll. Wobei so viele Daten
wie hier anfallen, gibt es wahrscheinlich auch zwischendurch noch genug zu entdecken und auszuwerten.
Also da wird einem nicht langweilig unbedingt.
Und es gibt auch noch die Injektoren. Also der LAC selbst wird drei Jahre stoppen,
aber die Injektoren werden so ein, eineinhalb Jahre stoppen.
Das heißt die ganze Physik in den anderen experimentellen Zonen,
die beginnt vorher schon wieder.
Also in dem Booster, in dem SPS, das läuft alles weiter, es ist nur der LAC.
Es ist ein kürzerer Stopp eben in diesem Maschinen.
Okay gut, aber dann nach einem anderthalb Jahr kann man da zumindest schon mal
wieder arbeiten, aber der LHC der muss dann halt noch richtig hübsch gestrichen
werden sozusagen, bis alles hübsch ist.
Okay, das heißt das ist dann sozusagen jetzt auch so der Ausblick für die zumindest
absehbare Zukunft, was jetzt auch schon ganz klar ist, dass das auf jeden Fall stattfinden wird.
Absolut.
Dieses High-Luminosity-LHC-Projekt, das ist die Priorität für das CERN im Moment,
dieses Upgrade durchzuführen.
Da ist alles unterwegs, um diese neuen Elemente gerade zu konstruieren und einzubauen.
Und das soll eben die LHC-Kette bis zum Jahr 2040 so in Betrieb halten,
soll dann natürlich nach dem Upgrade wesentlich höhere Statistik den Experimenten
zur Verfügung stellen, damit man schneller zu Entdeckungen kommen kann.
Ungefähr ein Faktor 10 wird sich diese Luminosität erhöhen nach diesem Upgrade von dem LHC.
Und das ist halt jener Schritt jetzt, um den LRC wirklich komplett auszunützen,
bis ans Ende seiner Lebensdauer sozusagen.
Und dann muss man halt schon darüber hinaus schauen und muss mal anfangen.
Also der LRC ist 2008 in Betrieb gegangen. Die ersten Diskussionen und Vorschläge
für so eine Maschine sind 1984 gemacht worden.
Also da ist wirklich eine lange Designphase, Entwicklung, Produktion,
Installation und alles dahinter.
Beim LHC ist es so, dass es damals schon in dem gleichen Tunnel,
wo der LHC heute ist, eine Maschine gab, wo Elektronen und Positronen,
also die Antiteilchen der Elektronen, beschleunigt und kollidiert wurden.
Und da hat man im Prinzip einerseits die Elektronenspeicherringe oder Kollider
und andererseits die Protonenmaschinen.
Mit Elektronen sagt man so, das sind Präzisionsmaschinen, weil die Elektronen
keine Substruktur haben.
Das heißt, da treffen wirklich Elektronen auf Elektronen und man kann ganz genau
physikalische Prozesse damit untersuchen.
Während diese Protonenmaschinen, Protonen, interne Struktur,
Quarks, Gluonen, das heißt, da treffen keine Teilchen, keine einzelnen Teilchen,
sondern da trifft man so ein Gemisch von Teilchen aufeinander.
Dadurch entstehen extrem viele verschiedene Produkte, viel Background,
den man auch gar nicht haben möchte, aber auch extrem viel Potenzial für neue Physik.
Und deswegen heißen diese Protonen-Maschinen dann Entdeckungsmaschinen,
oft, weil man damit eben neue Physik entdecken kann. Jetzt haben wir das Higgs-Boson
entdecken können vor zehn Jahren mit dem LHC.
Natürlich möchte man weitere Dinge entdecken, aber man möchte genauso die Higgs-Eigenschaften
ganz genau verstehen können. Und dafür braucht es im Prinzip wiederum so eine
Präzisionsmaschine mit höheren Energien.
Die Eigenschaften des Higgs-Bosons direkt messen kann.
Und deswegen wäre dann der nächste Schritt nach diesem High-Luminosity-LHC,
nennen wir dieses Studiegerad FCC,
Future Circular Collider, und das wäre dann eine Maschine, so wie es jetzt geplant
wird, von 91 Kilometer Länge, die eben genauso hier in die Region hineinpassen würde.
Also das ist auch dann schon sehr sehr herausfordernd in mehrerer Hinsicht.
Natürlich in Hinsicht von Magnetfeldern, die man braucht für diese Maschine,
in der Hinsicht von allein, wie baue ich diesen Tunnel, wie stabil ist das ganze
Gestein, wo ich diesen Tunnel hinbaue, wie hoch sind diese Zutrittspunkte.
Teilweise ist die Maschine dann unter dem Berg, da muss ich schon mal einen
sehr, sehr langen Access-Tunnel graben.
Was ist dann Sicherheitsaspekte, wenn da unten irgendetwas passiert,
wie komme ich rauf, wenn der Aufzug nicht funktioniert, all diese Dinge müssen dann beachtet werden.
Aber so ein FCC für Elektronen und Positronen, das wäre so im Prinzip der nächste
logische Schritt, was die Beschleunigerkette betrifft, um dann diese Higgs-Properties
im größeren Detail untersuchen zu können.
Und dann wird das auch so aufgezogen, dass man nach diesem FCC-II auch wiederum
einen Protonen-Protonen-Beschleuniger machen kann.
In dem gleichen Tunnel, in diesem gleichen 91 Kilometer Tunnel,
eben gleich wie es mit diesem LEP und
dem LAC war, dass man die vorhandene Infrastruktur wieder verwenden kann.
Gleichzeitig oder als potenzieller Nachfolger?
Als Nachfolger, genau.
Warum lässt sich das nicht gleichzeitig machen?
Weil dann auch die Kette, die dahinter steht, komplett andere Anforderungen
wieder hat. Wir müssen Elektronen, wir müssen Positronen zur Verfügung stellen.
Es sind auch die Zeitspannen, um wirklich all die Technologien,
die Magnetfelder und so einmal technologisch herstellen zu können für so einen
weiteren Protonen-Protonen-Kollider.
Das ist auch noch in weiterer Zukunft. Das heißt, Machbarkeit ist auch eine
andere Sache, da muss noch viel Forschung und Entwicklung hineingehen,
bis man technisch diese ganzen verschiedenen Bauteile einfach wirklich herstellen kann.
Deswegen sind das auch nicht die gleichen Zeitspannen.
Also 27 Kilometer ist ja schon eine ganze Menge Holz.
Im Prinzip was du ja sagst, du bist halt so Ingenieur und deine Maschine ist 27 Kilometer lang.
Das ist schon ein Autobahntunnel, der nur ein paar Kilometer lang ist,
wirft schon größere Wartungsfragen und Kontrollfragen auf sich,
aber allein den Arbeitsplatz mal abzugehen, mit dem Fahrrad ist man ja schon
den ganzen Tag unterwegs.
Ja auf jeden Fall. Die Fahrräder gibt es im Tunnel damit man sich fortbewegen kann.
Wie fährt man denn hin an so einen Ort des Geschehens? Ist halt irgendein Magnet am schwächeln.
Steigt man hier in den Tunnel und fährt da 10 Kilometer hin, macht man nichts?
Man steigt hier ins Auto, fährt hin zu einem der Access Points.
Und wie viel gibt es davon?
Am ELC gibt es so acht Access Points, die verteilt sind.
Einerseits bei den verschiedenen Experimenten, aber dann für die Hochfrequenz-Kavitäten zum Beispiel,
dann gibt es Kollimationssysteme, die dafür sorgen,
dass die Teilchen, die bei hoher Amplitude,
also hoher transversaler Position,
hoher horizontaler oder vertikaler Position, dass die quasi geschluckt werden
von diesem Kollimatorsystem,
bevor sie von den Magneten geschluckt werden würden,
weil wenn wir Teile im Magneten verlieren,
kann es dazu führen, dass dieses flüssige Helium sich erwärmt oder dass die
Spule dieser Supraleiter nicht mehr supraleitend ist,
weil er eine lokale Erwärmung hat, das ist dann ein so genannter Quench,
dann geht dieser Magnet dann von einem supraleitenden in einen normalleitenden
Zustand über und das möchte man einfach vermeiden während des Betriebs,
weil das dauert dann acht bis zwölf Stunden bis man wieder recoveren kann und
das ist natürlich Maschinenzeit, die dann verloren geht.
Und deswegen möchte man, bevor man solche Teilchen in den Magneten verliert,
möchte man sie lokalisiert in sogenannten Kollimatoren.
Das sind im Prinzip Metallblöcke, die möglichst nah am Strahl positioniert sind,
aber nicht zu nah, um den Hauptstrahl zu absorbieren,
aber eben Teilchen, die dann aufgrund der Kollisionen wird der Strahle auch
immer größer und größer,
dann kann es passieren, dass eben Strahlteilchen zu höherer Amplitude kommen
und die werden dann von diesen Metall-Kollimatoren absorbiert,
bevor sie den Magneten treffen würden.
So ein Absicherungssystem. Aber bist du schon mal rumgefahren?
Rumgefahren noch nie.
Ist auch ein bisschen langweilig.
Geht auch gar nicht, weil du hast dann diese Interaktionspunkte,
da ist dann wirklich die Maschine, der Beschleuniger ist getrennt von dem Experiment,
das dahinter in dieser großen Halle steht.
Da könntest du jetzt auch nicht weiterfahren.
Okay, es ist eh segmentiert.
Ja, es gibt verschiedene Sektoren, nennt man das im LHC zum Beispiel.
Okay, da ist man auf jeden Fall ganz gut unterwegs. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall
ein Maschinenpark, der sich sehen lassen kann und es ist die größte Maschine der Welt, oder?
Absolut, es ist die größte Maschine der Welt, der LHC. Der Beschleunigerkomplex
ist der größte Beschleunigerkomplex der Welt.
Also wir haben hier schon einiges an Potenzial zu bieten, das dann natürlich
auch sehr ansprechend ist für verschiedenste Institute, Universitäten dergleichen
aus aller Welt, die dann hierher kommen, um ihre Experimente durchzuführen.
Vielleicht zum Schluss nochmal so ein Blick in den Rest der Welt.
Das ist ja aber nicht das einzige Synchrotron.
Es gibt ja auch Beschleunigerringe an anderen Standorten.
Was sind denn so die nächstgrößten Systeme und gibt es irgendeinen der auch
nochmal ein ganz anderes Prinzip verfolgt oder andere technologische Ausrichtungen
hat in irgendeiner Form?
Also es gibt natürlich ein paar Laboratorien, die sich wirklich mit Grundlagenphysik beschäftigen.
Aber die Teilchenbeschleunigung oder die Anwendung der Teilchenbeschleuniger
in der Grundlagenphysik macht nur
ungefähr 4-5 Prozent der Anwendung der Teilchenbeschleuniger weltweit aus.
Natürlich gibt es einige größere Maschinen. Es gab zum Beispiel das Tevatron
Fermilab, die haben genauso Protonen-Antiprotonen-Kollisionen gemacht in der Nähe von Chicago.
Es gibt das Brookhaven National Lab in der Nähe von New York.
Dort gibt es den Relativistic Heavy Ion Collider.
Es gibt dann eben einerseits diese RIG, der Gold beschleunigen kann,
wie er auch die Bleionen beschleunigen kann und können, um dann so ein Quark-Gluon-Plasma
herzustellen, wie es zum Beispiel in dem Alice-Detektor vor allem untersucht wird.
Also um so eine Suppe von Teilchen im Prinzip zu erzeugen, die.
Wo jetzt keine Atomkerne mehr gebunden sind, wo alle Teilchen frei herum existieren
und diesen Status knapp nach dem Urknall im Prinzip zu reproduzieren.
Und das kann man am RIG untersuchen, das kann man am LAC untersuchen mit Blei.
Dann gibt es Programme in China zum Beispiel, um auch größere Beschleuniger
zu bauen, die existieren aber noch nicht. Das ist ein bisschen so vielleicht
ein Konkurrenzprogramm.
Es gab früher, am CERN gab es auch der SPS, der war früher mal ein Protonen-Antiprotonen-Kollider.
Der ist dann umgebaut worden, der hat begonnen als SPS, als Protonenmaschine,
wurde dann umgebaut in eine Protonen-Antiprotonen-Maschine und später wieder
zurückgebaut in eine reine Protonenmaschine.
Und dann gibt es halt extrem viele Anwendungen in Medizin,
in Industrie, von wesentlich kleineren Anlagen,
die Energien sind dann nicht mehr vergleichbar, aber gerade in Krankenhäusern,
wo man Radioisotope herstellt, um die dann für Bildgebung zu verwenden,
Positronenemissionstomographie, wo man etwas injiziert bekommt in den Körper,
das sich dann zum Beispiel an Tumorzellen anlagern kann, erzeugt dann Photonen,
die gemessen werden von Detektoren.
Diese Stoffe muss man irgendwo erzeugen, dann muss man sie in den Körper bringen.
Und dann gibt es natürlich auch Strahlentherapie, kann passieren mit Elektronen
und dann Gamma-Strahlen,
die erzeugt werden, es gibt Protonen oder Kohlenstoff-Ionen-Zentren,
die wirklich dazu dienen, dass jetzt Krebstumore behandelt werden.
Und je nachdem, ob man jetzt Elektronen verwendet zum Beispiel,
wenn man oberflächennahe Tumore hat, kann man relativ gut Elektronen verwenden,
weil die einen Großteil ihrer Energie nahe der Oberfläche, nahe der Haut nach
dem Eindringen in den Körper verlieren.
Andererseits dann, wenn man einen Tumor hat, der an kritischen Stellen sitzt,
jetzt zum Beispiel neben dem Herz, hinter dem Aug, im Gehirn irgendwo,
dann möchte man nicht unbedingt den Großteil der Energie beim Eintritt in den
Körper verlieren und dann weniger Energie am Schluss überhaben.
Da verwendet man Protonen und Kohlenstoff zum Beispiel, weil man mit denen dezidiert
einstellen kann, wo soll die Energie verloren werden und somit kann man wirklich
so einen Tumor scannen aus verschiedensten Richtungen und diese Tumorzellen
dann mit so einem Synchrotron zerstören.
Das heißt, das braucht dann aber für so Protonen- oder Kohlenstoffionentherapie
braucht es wirklich ein eigenes Beschleunigerzentrum mit eigenem LINAC,
Quelle LINAC, Synchrotron, verschiedenste Behandlungsräume, Transferlinien,
während so Elektronenbeschleuniger dann vielleicht so drei, vier,
fünf Meter Platz brauchen und dann wesentlich besser in ein Krankenhaus hineinpassen zum Beispiel.
Und dann gibt es das noch in der Industrie, dass man sterilisiert zum Beispiel,
Bakterien abtötet, dass man biologische Experimente versucht,
dass man in der Halbleiterindustrie die die Oberflächenbeschaffenheiten verändert,
indem man Ionen mit Beschleunigern einbringt in verschiedene Elemente.
Also es gibt wirklich eine riesige Bandbreite an Anwendungen von Beschleunigern,
die über die Grundlagenforschung hinaus geht.
Okay, also wenn man sich da ein bisschen auskennt, gibt es genug Betätigungsfelder
auf jeden Fall. Aber am CERN scheint ja noch genug abzusehen zu sein,
dass hier noch genug Ingenieursbedarf ist auf absehbare Zeit.
Ja, Alexander, dann würde ich sagen, haben wir es erstmal oder haben wir noch
irgendwas ganz Wichtiges vergessen, was du noch allen mit auf den Weg geben willst?
Naja, vielleicht so.
Abschluss können wir noch ein bisschen die Verbindung zum Kosmos wiederum machen
mit einem der Experimente, das wir auch hier haben, nämlich Cloud.
Jenes Experiment, das untersucht, wie Wolken formiert werden,
wie verschiedenste kleine Teilchen, wie Aerosole am Himmel,
in den verschiedenen Atmosphären, Ebenen zu dieser Wolkenbildung beitragen und
vor allem wie der Einfluss von kosmischen Strahlen auf diese Wolkenproduktion ist.
Da haben wir eine sogenannte Cloud Chamber, das ist im Prinzip eine große Stainless-Steel-Chamber,
die extrem gute Oberflächeneigenschaften aufweist.
Innerhalb dieser Kammer werden dann verschiedene Gase eingelassen,
verschiedene Aerosole zugefügt.
Was heißt denn extrem gute Oberflächenbeschärfung? Also gut in welcher Hinsicht? Glatt?
Genau, damit sich dort eben an den Wänden keine Elemente anhaften können,
sondern dass die wirklich in diesem Volumen der Kammer dann existieren und zu
der Wolkenbildung beitragen.
Und dann kann man einerseits untersuchen, wie so Aerosole in der Luft auch als
Keime für Wolken dienen dienen und wie die physikalischen Modelle,
übereinstimmen mit diesen Experimenten und andererseits kann man dann von dem
PS einen Strahl von Protonen auf wiederum so ein Target schicken,
Sekundärteilchen erzeugen, die dann durch diese Kammer hindurch gehen und sich
anschauen, wie diese quasi nachgebildeten kosmischen Strahlen die Wolkenbildung beeinflussen.
Tun sie denn?
Sie tun auf jeden Fall zu einer gewissen Art und Weise.
Man kann nämlich solche durch Kollisionen, wenn diese Teilchen kollidieren mit
den Molekülen, dann werden andere Teilchen erzeugt, andere Aerosole,
die dann wiederum ein Keim sein können für weitere Wolkenbildung und so.
Was die Frage ist jetzt natürlich auch im Hinblick auf Klimawandel,
inwiefern sind diese Wolken ausschlaggebend für den Klimawandel,
wie gut passen unsere Modelle, wie gut können wir das vorhersagen,
weil das eine große Unsicherheit ist, um die Zukunft auch vorauszusagen.
Und deswegen gibt dieses Experiment auf jeden Fall gute, sage ich mal,
grundlegende Einblicke, wie die Physik dahinter funktioniert und wie wir unsere
Modelle verbessern können, um
in Zukunft einfach immer besser und bessere Vorhersagen machen zu können.
Wahnsinn, unglaublich praktisch so ein Beschleuniger. Ich finde,
jeder sollte einen haben. Vielleicht gibt es ja demnächst auch im Supermarkt.
Alexander, Vielen vielen Dank für die Ausführung, das war sehr aufschlussreich und spannend.
Dankeschön, hat mich gefreut beim Gespräch, danke dir.
Ja und ich bedanke mich auch wieder fürs Zuhören hier bei Raumzeit.
Bald geht es weiter hier im Programm mit dem CERN und noch so einiges auf euch zu. Tschüss, bis bald!